a record fine for meta from the Irish
data commission 1.3 billion dollars for
breaching Europe's General data
protection regulations
for sending the personal information of
millions of European Facebook users to
the US without properly protecting them
from potential U.S surveillance as well
as the fine in order for meta to stop
transferring U.S data to the U.S within
the next five months meta says it will
appeal the ruling and called the fine
unjustified and unnecessary in a
statement they said we are disappointed
to have been singled out when using the
same legal mechanism as thousands of
other companies looking to provide
services in Europe this decision is
flawed unjustified and sets a dangerous
precedent for the countless other
companies transferring data between the
EU and U.S majority of Facebook users in
Europe probably weren't aware that their
personal information stored on the
platform could be vulnerable to U.S
surveillance nor that a ruling like this
could see Facebook and Europe suspended
but a new pact to facilitate the safer
transfer of their data to the US is in
the pipeline and will be fully
functioning by summer avoiding any
Facebook disruption the EU says the new
system will give it better protection to
users
we're finalizing a framework for data
protection between the EU and the us we
expect this to be fully functional by
the summer and this will guarantee
stability and legal certainty both to
support these businesses and would also
guarantee strict protection of the
private lives of citizens
but privacy X
the United States does not have a data
prediction or privacy federal law that
protects a non-american in the way they
protect American and what it's been
particularly problematic for for many
many years has really increased when
Tech Giants are monetizing personal data
of millions of us around the world well
there is not this Federal level of
protection for information both on the
commercial sector and then the scope of
surveillance law in the US is so broad
the case dates back 10 years when U.S
intelligence whistleblower Edward
Snowden warned that Tech Giants were
handing data to U.S surveillance
agencies in 2022 the European court of
justice warned tech companies to ensure
user data was safe but they feel meta
did not listen this record fine now has
their full attention Charlie Angela Al
Jazeera London